bonsoir à tous ses points de vue et
c'est vendredi donc on retrouve comme
souvent ce jour de la semaine
nos deux duellistes ou peut-être
duettistes dépend des sujets bonsoir
ferghana ziari vous êtes analyste en
politiques publiques à l'iref et vous
êtes également le délégué général de
l'académie des sciences humaines bonsoir
guillaume bernard pour servir chacun
sait désormais que vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'institut catholique
d'études supérieures et auteur de la
guerre à droite aura bien lieu qui a été
publié aux éditions des clés de bruère
c'était une surprise car à la première
lecture ce le vote du sénat n'avait pas
été celui là mais la haute assemblée a
décidé cette semaine de rejeter
l'article de la loi dite bioéthique qui
ouvre aux couples de femmes l'accès à la
procréation médicalement assistée
écoutez ce qu'en disait à la tribune
bruno retailleau c'est le président du
groupe l air au sénat et il a expliqué
pourquoi il était contre sur la pma son
père c'est bien faire primer la liberté
individuelle sur le principe de
vulnérabilité c'est bien faire primer la
volonté des adultes sur je crois là
l'intérêt et le droit des enfants
je pense que celui qui prend tous les
risques sur la pma sans père c'est bien
sûr l'enfant
ceci ne fait pas les affaires de la
majorité en marche
vous savez que ce projet faisait partie
du programme présidentiel même si
emmanuel macron avait dit pendant sa
campagne qu'il fallait qu'ils aient
consensus sur ce sujet écoutez il ya une
brune peavey c'est l'une des patronnes
de la république en marche à l'assemblée
nationale elle dit deux choses 1 les
sénateurs ne sont pas assez moderne
de toute façon c'est l'assemblée qui
aura le dernier mot faut vivre avec son
époque il faut vivre avec son temps et
là malheureusement les sénateurs
fondation alors je dirais pas ça comme
ça mais en tout cas ils n'ont pas je
crois compris les enjeux sociétaux de ce
texte qui est important pour des
centaines et des milliers de familles et
donc nous en tout cas c'est quelque
chose que nous souhaitons porter
jusqu'au bout et le porter très haut
enfin ça va finir par passer parce
qu'effectivement aujourd'hui dans notre
système institutionnel c'est l'assemblée
nationale qui qui a le dernier mot il
faut vivre avec son époque c'est un
argument comme un autre guillaume
bernard comme un autre vraiment très
très commun comme arguments n'ont cessé
ces déplorables
je suis évidemment satisfait du fait que
le que le sénat ait finalement rejeté
cet article c'est pas le seul évidemment
c'est celui dont on parle le plus mais
il ya d'autres sujets qui sont
évidemment très important c'est d'en
particulier sur la question de la la
recherche sur les embryons et le sénat a
là aussi tu vires est mis la ola à des
dérives progressiste en particulier la
possibilité de de mettre en place des
embryons transgéniques et est chimérique
donc oui de manière générale c'est
satisfaisant simplement évidemment
malheureusement le député en marche que
nous venons d'écouter a raison il y aura
puisqu'on en est à la deuxième lecture
dans chacune des assemblées il y aura
donc une commission mixte paritaire
vraisemblablement pour pouvoir trouver
un texte de compromis entre les deux
assemblées et puis ensuite
et bien de toute façon c'est l'assemblée
nationale si jamais il n'y a pas de
texte de compromis qui est trouvée qui
tranchera donc la majorité en marche va
pouvoir imposer on peut imposer cela
mais cela dit c'est vrai que retarder
les choses
favoriser le débat et le fait qu'il n'y
ait pas simplement qu'un débat en
catimini dans les assemblées mais
également dans les médias bien ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas plus mal
voilà ferghana diaries pour vous donner
les coulisses de la préparation de cette
émission je ne me suis pas surpris par
la position de guillaume bernard parce
qu'il ne l'a pas caché depuis longtemps
en revanche je ne connaissais pas la
vôtre c'est d'autant plus intéressant de
vous entendre sur ce sujet est ce que
vous trouvez que le sénat a eu raison ou
non écoutez moi je suis favorable à la
pma de manière générale en tout cas sur
le plan juridique
quoique je trouve l'argument utilisé par
la porte parole dans marche complètement
nul c'est à dire qu'on voit c'est pas
une question d'époque c'est une question
de principe
vous savez que je m'inscris dans une
tradition intellectuelle qui s'appelle
le libéralisme et au nom de cette
tradition qui qui donc
remonta à john locke je considère que
les êtres humains sont propriétaires de
leur corps et donc qu'ils doivent
pouvoir en disposer comme ils le veulent
pour peu qu'il ne porte pas atteinte aux
intérêts à la personne à la vie au bien
de quelqu'un d'autre or je ne considère
pas que le fait d'utiliser la pma pour
donner la vie soit porté atteinte à
l'intérêt d'un enfant et donc la
criminalisation de cet acte médical
puisque aujourd'hui c'est bien de cela
dont il s'agit
quand on parle d'interdire à la pma ou
de maintenir son interdiction c'est de
maintenir sa criminalisation aujourd'hui
le code pénal réprime très sévèrement
celui qui s'adonneraient à une
procréation médicalement assistée donc
pour les femmes seules ou les couples
homosexuels
je ne suis pas certain que c'est le rôle
du législateur que de mandater des
policiers pour réprimer ceux qui
s'adonneraient à cet acte médical et par
ailleurs c'est vrai que j'ai tendance à
m'étonner aussi des arguments utilisés
par les conservateurs puisqu'il s'agit
ici de procréer de données l'avim qui
célèbre la vie humaine
eh bien je ne peux qu'être satisfait de
la possibilité donnée offerte aux femmes
qui le souhaitent d'avoir un enfant ce
qui ne constitue pas une attaque dirigée
contre la femme
traditionnel encore une fois il ne
s'agit pas de forcer tout le monde à
utiliser la pma mais après tout c'est
une liberté qui ne fait de mal à
personne les études aujourd'hui sur les
enfants issus de ce genre de famille
montrent qu'ils ne sont pas victimes de
préjudices particulier alors pourquoi
s'y opposer je ne trouve pas de raison
valable en ce qui me concerne
alors je vais vous les donnez vous le
voulez question oui est ce que vous vous
reconnaissez dans ce vocable
conservateur guillaume bernard oui
pourquoi pas alors je pense que je suis
un peu plus que conservateurs c'est à
dire que j'ai une drôle ans l'année à
défendre pourquoi parfois moi j'accepte
le terme ça ne me dérange pas avant
c'était de la rente ai mais en
l'occurrence non non non je je je veux
bien rentrer dans le camp des
conservateurs
simplement je ne défends pas le
conservatisme qui ne seraient que je
dirais sociologiquement ordonné à au
fait de maintenir une situation telle
qu'elle est mais dans l'idée que c'est
pour défendre et pour permettre le
véhiculer des idées plus de type
classique 1 que des idées de type
moderne voilà alors sur le fond je
trouve que la manière de cas fergane
d'aborder la question est effectivement
très bonne d'abord mais évidemment j'ai
abouti à des conclusions différentes
pourquoi parce que on se focalise
aujourd'hui sur la question de savoir si
on va étendre ou non la pma aux femmes
seules et aux couples de femmes
homosexuelles
or le coeur de la question et c'est en
cela que je diverge quelque peu des
organisations qui manifestent
régulièrement dans la rue contre ce
projet de loi c'est que je pense que
c'est la pma tout court qui pose
problème
et pourquoi est-ce qu'elle pose problème
parce que tout simplement pour pouvoir
procéder à la simulation d'un embryon
eh bien il faut faire un tri c'est à
dire que il y a dans cette pratique de
la pma et bien un eugénisme qui ne dit
pas son nom
donc bien sûr la pm a dit son père elle
va créer des enfants ou permettre de
donner naissance à des enfants que l'on
va délibérément privé de père c'est un
problème mais au delà même de ce simple
souci il y a deux toute façon le
problème de la pma et
même c'est à dire le fait que et bien
c'est une génisse mme et c'est le fait
que l'on instrumentalise finalement la
vie que je défends pour le coup moi
aussi véritablement mais qui est une vie
autre c'est pas la vie des parents
l'embryon qui va nous donner un être
humain c'est une vie qui est
indépendante
le corps de la femme porte l'embryon
mais l'embryon est un corps différent
est un être différent de celui de la
femme c'est la raison pour laquelle
aussi je pense que la matrice de toutes
ces évolutions bioéthique
c'est la question de l'avortement et qu'
on ne peut pas si on veut véritablement
s'opposer à ces évolutions aux
progressistes en matière de moeurs et de
bioéthique simplement s'arc bouter sur
les dernières évolutions qui nous sont
imposés mais qu'il le faut qu'il faut
refuser les faits cliquer et qu'il faut
remonter à la matrice du problème
il est donc dans le fond essayer
d'amener l'adversaire politiques ou
intellectuelles sur son terrain et pas
simplement je dirais réagir au fur et à
mesure qu'il ya des évolutions
ponctuelles ça c'est une divergence de
stratégie que je peux avoir avec la
manif pour tous ou ce genre de choses je
le dis publiquement parce que j'ai eu
l'occasion de le leur dire en privé donc
je ne les prends pas je ne les prend pas
à revers je suis parfaitement loyal avec
eux et j'interviens et je manifeste avec
eux sans aucun problème mais je les
trouve un tout petit peu le redirai
timorais exactement exactement passé sur
ce sujet farahnaz diaries d'une d'un
risque d'eugénisme
on sait qu' il n'y a pas suffisamment de
donneurs de sperme et que donc il va
falloir à un moment ou à un autre pour
ces femmes qui souhaitent avoir un
enfant par pma accéder à une sorte de
marché et là évidemment elles vont dire
moi je veux souhaiterait la préférence à
voir
tel est l caractéristiques pour les
gammes être que je vais recevoir
est-ce que ça ça vous choque ou est ce
que comme libérale vous trouverez que là
encore c'est la liberté de la femme de
choisir quel type d'enfant elle voudrait
avoir écouté sur le plan moral c'est
vrai que ça peut poser des questions
maintenant sur le plan juridique encore
une fois s'il s'agit simplement de
considérer la liberté pour la femme de
faire ce qu'elle souhaite tant que ça ne
nuit pas à autrui
je ne vois pas là encore quel est le
problème sur le plan de la justice et je
trouve l'argument de l'intérêt de
l'enfant assez étrange puisque ici
l'alternative est entre n'être donc
d'une pma ou ne pas exister alors est ce
qu'on considère que l'intérêt supérieur
ici de l'enfance c'est de ne pas exister
que cette non existence est préférable
au fait de naître d'une d'une pma sans
père ou d'une paix d'une pme dans un
couple homosexuel je trouve cette
position un peu un peu étrange parce
qu'après tout on peut aussi se dire que
la vie d'un enfant peut tout à fait
s'épanouir dans ce genre de famille
alors pourquoi dans ce cas là s'est
frayé de 2,2 de la possibilité donnée à
ces à ces femmes d'utiliser la pma est
par ailleurs moyenne quand même une
question soit une fois éthique aussi qui
me dérange c'est que dans le principe
même de l'interdiction de cette pratique
il y à l'idée que l'état serait légitime
à disposer de notre corps à notre place
et ça philosophiquement ça me dérange
beaucoup
c'est ce qu'un juriste comme daniel
borrillo appelle un jacobinisme
bioéthique l'idée que tu n'aies lmnp
l'état central serait lui même apte à
anould dépossédé de ce qu'on fait de
notre corps or si l'on ne me prouve pas
que cette pratique ici portent atteinte
véritablement à la vie de quelqu'un et
bien je ne vois pas là encore en quoi on
devrait criminaliser cette pratique même
si sur le plan moral je comprend
effectivement que les conservateurs ou
qui est des gens qui ont une vision plus
traditionalistes de la famille puisse
regarder cette pratique d'un oeil
méfiant mais je pense qu'il faut
distinguer des 2 et roland vous allez
bien sûr répondre
guillaume bernad mais je voudrais donner
la parole aux internautes parce que vous
êtes très nombreux et on vous en
remercie à réagir c'est un sujet fort et
un sujet qui vous passionne alors
globalement nos internautes sont plutôt
favorables à la décision au vote des
sénateurs
un enfant n'est pas un produit de
supermarché nous dînerons sur youtube le
sénat a raison kriss kross sur
lefigaro.fr qui considère lui que le
sénat aurait dû carrément rejeté
totalement le texte
la pma samper nous dit j katla sur
lefigaro.fr
comme son nom l'indiqué c'est une loi
qui prive les enfants d'un père alors
c'est un chris kraus dit je suis libéral
en économie mais conservateurs en
matière de moeurs
aucun parti ne me représentent
finalement ça c'est vrai que ce serait
un sujet qu'on pourrait aborder un os qu
est-ce que quand on est libéral il il
faut l'être de façon absolue au nom de
la cohérence ou non or d'autres
réactions celle de nova sur youtube pour
une personne seule c'est une aberration
un enfant est le fruit de l'amour de
deux personnes yoakim toujours sur
youtube un enfant n'est ni un jouet ni
un objet de consommation
christophe soixante dix huit sur
lefigaro.fr l'audi et après la gpa point
d'exclamation 7 gpa qui crée plus de
problèmes qu'elle n'en résout estime
olympe petit 74 nous dit ne pas avoir
d'enfant naturellement ça fait mal
heureux de ne pas avoir d'enfant
naturellement virgules cela fait
malheureusement partie de la vie et puis
anne sur youtube l'ultime stade du
libéralisme et du capitalisme c'est
l'humain qui est devenu un objet le vote
sur twitter est plus partagée que ne le
laissent penser les réactions que je
vous livre le sénat at il eu raison de
refuser l'extension de la pma pour les
couples de femmes et les femmes seules
c'est oui mais à 67% donc on est dans
deux ordres de grandeur de deux tirs à
thiers et puis je veux pas oublier
richard et nicole 06 qui lui disent que
de toute façon à la fin c'est
l'assemblée voir emmanuel macron qui
décide
guillaume bernard je vous repasse la
parole merci j'inviterais notre
téléspectateurs à être effectivement
cohérent et à être entièrement
conservateur parce qu'il se posait la
question de savoir s'il fallait qu'il
soit entièrement libéral ou non il peut
être entièrement conservateur et ça ne
l'empêchera pas d'être favorable aux
libertés économiques n'y a pas besoin
d'être libéral pour être pour les
libertés
bon cela dit c'était une parenthèse je
voulais répondre à fergane sur un pro
qui est extrêmement important bien
entendu que une fois que l'enfant est
conçu et bien je suis naturellement
favorable au fait qu'il est qu'on le
laisse en vie puisqu'il est déjà envie
mais le problème dans la pma c'est que
ce sont tous les autres enfants que l'on
tue pour pouvoir donner naissance à
celui que l'on va à ces mines et est
donc cessé avec des embryons tous les
embryons surnuméraires qui sont congelés
ou qui sont détruits et donc évidemment
ça pose un problème un grave problème
éthique parce que on crée donc des vies
les embryons qui vont être surnuméraires
pour pouvoir donner la vie à 1
tant mieux bien sûr mais on a créé de la
vie pour au final au service d'une autre
vie c'est à dire qu'on instrumentalise
tous les enfants tous les embryons qui
sont créés et et dont on ne respecte
évidemment pas la singularité par
ailleurs évidemment je crois que c'est
un véritable enjeu de se poser la
question est ce que l'enfant est un
droit ou est-ce que et bien dans le fond
on doit considérer que les adultes ont
une responsabilité vis-à-vis de l'enfant
bien sûr l'enfant ne demande pas à
naître ne demande pas à vivre mais c'est
justement parce qu'il est entièrement
innocent parce qu'il est entièrement
dépendant de ce qui lui donne la vie
qu'on ne peut pas le traiter comme une
chose juste pour répondre sur est ce que
l'entente est un droit je pense pas que
les que quiconque pose la question en
ces termes il n'ya pas de droit à
l'enfant l'enfant n'est pas une espèce
de créances qu'on attendrait de l'état
qui seraient obligés de nous fournir un
enfant sont nés
de cela dont il s'agit ici c'est une
liberté négative et regarde c'est ce que
vous défendez
mais certaines personnes qui
revendiquent cette paix est mal à eux le
conçoivent comme une union où l'exigence
une créance sur le thème savez bien on
n'est pas obligé d'adhérer à cette
vision là des choses on peut aussi être
situé sur le terrain de liberté purement
négative à savoir liberté encore une
fois de progrès y compris selon des
méthodes qui ne sont pas très orthodoxes
pour peu que cela porte atteinte à va
encore une fois l'intérêt de personne et
que ça permette à une vie de naître de
la même manière que je trouve que
l'argument de la marchandisation de
l'enfant est un petit peu un espèce
d'homme de paille parce que personne ne
considéraient les enfants comme des
objets ce sont des êtres humains à part
entière et la preuve en est
qu'aujourd'hui un enfant n'est pas la
propriété de ses parents un pardon ne
peut pas disposer de son enfant comme
comme ils le souhaitent et pas le
démembrer le tuer ça c'est pénalement
répréhensible donc non il ne s'agit pas
de 2,2 de marchandises et les enfants il
s'agit tout simplement de cesser de
criminaliser une pratique qui selon moi
est tout à fait pacifique
même si encore une fois on peut tout à
fait en tant que conservateur et
traditionalistes être ne pas regarder
cette pratique d'un bon oeil mais enfin
il faut distinguer entre ce qui relève
du crime et de ce qui peut paraître
déplaisant aux yeux de certains selon
moi merci beaucoup je vous propose un
dernier point de vue celui de christophe
sur lefigaro.fr qui je pense va vous
mettre d'accord christophe naudi la
parentalité c'est d'avoir des droits et
des devoirs vis-à-vis d'un enfant on est
d'accord là dessus
oui oui si on veut mais chose que mes
droits avait droit peut-être non
titulaires de l'autorité parentale et la
stabilité de voir à une autorité c'est
mieux comme ça
ce que ferghana dit c'est que et ce sur
quoi je ne suis pas tout à fait d'accord
tout de même c'est que tant que l'enfant
n'est pas né vivant et viable vous savez
bien que aujourd'hui on est en capacité
de pouvoir l'éliminer de le considérer
comme une chose malheureusement malgré
même après les délais légaux permettant
d'avoir recours à l'avortement parce que
lorsqu'un tiers provoque année un
accident qui provoque la mort de cet
enfant à naître
eh bien on ne considère pas qu'il ya eu
homicide c'est donc ça c'est extrêmement
grave ça c'était avant la naissance
je vous propose de parler d'un autre
sujet qui t'a c'est grave
lui aussi c'est celui de l'éventuel
rapatriement des femmes de djihadistes
pourquoi en parlant nous aujourd'hui
bien parce que depuis le début de la
semaine une femme s'appelle pascal
descamps qui vit à boulogne-sur-mer a
entamé une grève de la faim pour faire
revenir sa fille âgée de 32 ans qui est
actuellement emprisonné dans le nord de
la syrie cette jeune femme a quatre
enfants et elle est partie en syrie
faire rejoindre des chaprais s'être
converties à l'islam
son premier compagnon est mort et
ensuite remariée avec un autre
djihadistes qui est lui aussi est mort
et voilà donc cette affaire dramatique
je vous propose d'écouter le point de
vue d'eric dupond-moretti le ministre de
la justice
ce qui est intéressant c'est que lui
même n'est pas tout à fait sûrs d'avoir
une opinion
la réponse de coeur et puis il ya la
réponse possible et se sont pas
forcément les mêmes réponses
en même temps on ne va pas oublier que
des français nous ont trahis pour les
nous combattre et nous combattrons
profit de l'état islamique ferghana
ziari qu'en pensez vous sur toutes
celles et ceux qui ont volontairement
rejoint une organisation terroriste mais
nous a déclaré la guerre
moi je ne vois pas pourquoi on ferait
preuve d'une quelconque charité envers
des adultes pleinement responsable de
même qu'ils ont fait le choix de tourner
les armes contre notre pays et je trouve
assez gonflé que ces gens
ose encore demander une quelconque aide
humanitaire à la civilisation qu'il
compte véritablement détruire alors pour
les enfants c'est un autre sujet
beaucoup plus juste un instant à des
représentations n'était pas complète
cette femme dont la mère réclame le
retour est gravement malade pardonnez
moi je referme
je vous le redonne la parole pour moi le
critère qui importe ce n'est pas la
santé c'est l'état de minorité de
majorité des individus impliqués c'est à
dire que dans le cas d'un enfant qui a
été instrumentalisé par ses parents qui
a été victime d'une propagande et dans
l'âge de cerveau il serait évidemment
pour nous criminel de laisser ses
enfants entre les mains de ces gens qui
ont rejoint un organisme terroriste donc
pour les enfants mineurs la question se
pose maintenant pour les majeurs
pleinement responsable et vacciné pardon
alors je sais que qui avec un grand sage
qui a dit qu'un jour il fallait venir
ses ennemis et peut-être que guillaume
bernard à une lecture littérale du
sermon sur la montagne mais ce n'est pas
mon cas et je le considère en effet
qu'il lui que ces gens là aucune créance
sur notre pays dès lors qu'ils ont
rejoint une organisation qui a déclaré
la guerre
eh bien écoutez sur ce sujet là je vais
plutôt partagé la vie de la vie de
fergane évidemment
je pense qu'il est indécent de demander
à la puissance publique de rapatrier ces
personnes pourquoi veux tu houdré vous
pourquoi voudrait-on rapatrier des jeans
est des djihadistes des personnes qui
ont délibérément fait le choix
effectivement de mener une guerre et et
de porter un uniforme autre que celui de
l'armée française bon ça me paraît
absolument ubuesque d'avoir cette cette
revendication ce serait pour la l'or
pour la juger non seulement pour leur
famille en france mais aussi pour la
juger de façon équitable
on lui demanderait des comptes quand
alors pourquoi voulez vous qu'elles ne
soient pas jugés de manière équitable là
où elle est emprisonnée je suppose que
si elle est emprisonnée là bas et c'est
parce que elle a été arrêtée qu'on lui
reproche un certain nombre d'infractions
je regrette mais en droit pénal on juge
l'infraction
là où a été commise l'infraction le sait
le principe de l'application
territoriale du droit et à partir du
moment où effectivement elle est bien
susceptible d'être jugée nous n'avons
pas à une commande ira a revendiqué le
fait de la de la rapatrier parce
qu'elles seraient de nationalité parce
que ces personnes seront où ces
personnes seraient de nationalité
française
je vais même plus loin je pose
sincèrement la question de savoir si ces
personnes sont véritablement encore de
nationalité française
il n'y a aucune raison de considérer que
des personnes qui trahissent qui rentre
dans une organisation terroriste est une
organisation qui nous a déclaré la
guerre soit encore et bien doivent être
encore considérées comme un compatriote
je vous rappelle quand même c'est
stéphane courtois qui me l'a appris et
et je l'en remercie grandement que et
bien sous le gouvernement daladier n'est
ce pas non seulement le parti communiste
qui est bien appliqué les packs de
germano soviétique de non agression
avait été dissous et que en outre
maurice thorez qui n'avait qu'une seule
nationalité parce que pendant des mois
on nous a expliqué qu'on ne pouvait pas
retirer la nationalité à quelqu'un qui
n'avait que la nocivité française est
bien maurice thorez avait été condamné
pour désertion et avait vu sa
nationalité française
la seule qui l'avait être
être retirée alors la suite de
l'histoire on la sait il va finir vice
président du conseil après la libération
parce que staline s'est retrouvé dans le
camp des vainqueurs la deuxième guerre
mondiale
enfin ça n'empêche que oui on peut
parfaitement lu moralement et
politiquement retirer la nationalité
française à ceux qui nous trahissent ça
me paraît parfaitement normal
l'historien stéphane courtois auquel
vous faites allusion est l'auteur du
livre noir du communisme absolument qui
est un ouvrage absolument majeur sur
l'histoire du 20e siècle et est ce que
vous vous appliqueriez la même rigueur
aux enfants qui eux n'ont rien demandé
alors l'argument qui a été utilisé par
fergane je le partage c'est à dire le
fait qu'à partir du moment où ils ont
été contraints ou les enfants ont été
contraints mais là pour le coup on peut
considérer qu effectivement il faudrait
peut-être les rapatrier cela dit ils ont
la nationalité française pour quelle
raison parce que leurs parents l'ont
partir du moment où leurs parents perdre
la nationalité française on pourrait
peut-être considéré que même d'une
certaine manière perdrait la cause
je vais peut-être un peu loin fois la
cause qui les conduirait à être français
je vais un peu loin mais on pourrait
effectivement considérer en espérant
qu'il puisse être véritablement si tenté
que ce soit possible des red et
radicaliser on pourrait penser qu'il
faudrait effectivement pour ce qui est
des enfants pensée allait rapatrier
après tout le problème c'est le problème
delà de la limite c'est pas le sujet
d'aujourd'hui la limite du consentement
la sexualité le la limite je dirais du
du consentement je dirais à l'adhésion
est ce que des enfants qui ont passé
l'âge de raison et qu'ils ont eux-mêmes
peut-être commis des actes délictueux ou
criminel est ce que cela ne devrait-il
pas être considéré comme étant déjà
responsable la majorité d'une certaine
manière pénale elle n'est pas à 18 ans
elle est bien plus basse
on commence à être responsable
pénalement de ses actes à 13 ans et à
partir de 16 ans eh bien on peut être
parfaitement jugé par une cour d'assises
pour mineurs
donc je pense que l'âge devrait être
abaissée par rapport à l'âge de 18 ans
sur twitter
vous êtes là pour le coup assez près
presque unanime doit-on rapatrier en
france les femmes de djihadistes c'est
une question que nous vous posons vous
pouvez donc donner votre avis en même
temps que vous faites vos commentaires
sur le hashtag point de vue doit-on
rapatrier en france les femmes de
djihadistes et bien c'est non à 89%
je suis en train de chercher un argument
un commentaire plutôt qu'ils ne soient
pas sur cette ligne mais je n'en trouve
pas et christophe 78 qu'il reste en
syrie clairement non je suis contre
olympe sur lefigaro.fr non au
rapatriement des femmes de djihadistes
la sécurité de 67 millions d'habitants
ne doit pas céder face aux
sentimentalisme nous dit anne sur
youtube fils considère qu'il est tout
simplement hallucinant que nous posions
même la question difficile d'assurer que
ces personnes ne récidive pas nous dit
une autre sur le figaro.fr christophe 78
considèrent que ce sera difficile
il serait difficile de juger cette femme
car il manquera toujours des preuves
et puis eric sur youtube qui nous donne
cette réflexion pleine de sagesse la
violence engendre la violence est ce que
vous êtes surpris faca nasillard et que
le gouvernement fasse preuve d'une forme
de le fermeté sur ce sujet même eric
dupond moretti
pourtant j'ai des avocats oui il a
changé d'avis vous faites bien de
rappeler guillaume bernard que qu'est-ce
qui explique ça à votre avis la faire
annuler pâtit le fait que l'opinion
publique française a été suffisamment
échaudés par les attentats terroristes
ces derniers temps c'est à dire que ni
un moment où effectivement le niveau de
tolérance vis-à-vis de ces comportements
baisse et où on fait preuve de moins de
clémence mais c'est tout à fait naturel
et sain de se comporter ainsi
alors maintenant il faut pas se
contenter d'une réponse on va dire
purement politique et militaire
face à ce phénomène puisque on est face
à un phénomène idéologique globale qui
nécessite donc une réponse culturelle
idéologique intellectuelle on sait que
les causes de ces
le comportement terroriste est bien
réside dans la religion musulmane elle
même donc c'est elle qu'il faut
interroger c'est elle qu'il faut réfuter
et ça malheureusement ce n'était pas un
exercice auquel on est très habitué
c'est pas quelque chose qu'on n'ose
aborder encore tout à fait honnêtement
on est aujourd'hui enfermés dans le
fantasme d'une réforme de l'islam et
d'un islam de france comme si il était
possible de pacifier le contenu du coran
qui aujourd'hui inspirent ces
comportements terroristes grande
majorité de musulmans pacifiques et que
donc c'est tout sonnait la production
sont la preuve vivante non à montpellier
le coran il existe aujourd'hui des
musulmans qui se revendiquent de l'islam
mais qu'ils sont pacifiques mais qui en
réalité sont des musulmans dits modérés
et quand on dit que ce sont des
musulmans modérés dire que la vertu de
l'islam réside dans la modération
eh bien ça revient implicitement à
admettre les sens autoritaires et
totalitaires de cette religion après
tout aucun droit de l'hommiste aucun
pacifiste pour rassurer son auditoire
dit vous inquiétez pas je suis un
pacifiste modéré donc ces gens sont
quand il ya un musulman tolérant il faut
se demander s'il est tolérant grâce à
l'islam et en dépit de l'islam et pour
ça il faut s'intéresser à la théologie
musulmane et quand vous vous y
intéressez vous vous rendez compte
qu'ils sont tolérants en dépit de
l'islam et non pas grâce à cette
religion ce qui implique donc de réfuter
cette religion en tant que tels si on
veut vaincre cette idéologie bien
comment est bien en appelant au sens
critique de ceux qui se réclament de
l'islam en demandant mais finalement ce
coran qui se dit un créé est-ce qu'on
essaie vraiment sûr c'est une oeuvre
divine contenu de toutes les
contradictions de ce texte un dieu bon
et miséricordieux est il vraiment ce
qu'il prétend être
quand l'application de ces ordres
conduit à tant de désolation sur terre
ces versets qui nous sermonner qui nous
disent qu'il faut aller en enfer si on
ne croit pas en dieu
est ce que c'est vraiment l'oeuvre d'un
dieu ou plutôt d'un homme un peu jaloux
et un peu possessif donc désacraliser
déconstruire l'islam en france on a de
très grands experts qui excelle dans la
déconstruction et bien moi je sais que
je propose les engagés pour
combattre cette idéologie au même titre
qu'on a pu combattre d'autres idéologies
totalitaires au 20e siècle
le barrage était encore pas mieux avec
j'ose dire je crains que fergane des
raisons si les les jeux mais pour
répondre à votre question me semble que
le gouvernement que l'exécutif essaye
dans le fond de d'obtenir une forme de
sécularisation d'un certes de l'islam
d'un certain nombre de ces courants et
que par conséquent cela deviendrait
incohérent d'essayer de négocier avec le
cfcm une charte très discutable
d'ailleurs d'à côté et de l'autre côté
d'accueillir effectivement des des
djihadistes qui sont pour le coup
évidemment l'antithèse de ce que le
gouvernement essaye de négocier avec
certaines institutions plus ou moins
représentative donc voilà je crois que
pour le coup il y à une stratégie
politique mais qui moi m'inquiète dans
le sens où sous prétexte qu'il faudrait
et bien contrôler les manifestations
radicales de l'islam pourrait conduire à
un affadissement et à une abolition de
tout de tout un pan de liberté pour tout
le monde
on le voit par exemple avec
l'instruction en famille avec le
principe déclaratif de l'autorisation
plutôt qui va suçant doute remplacer
l'autorisation pour les écoles dites
hors contrat voilà je crois de
l'administratif des associations et ça
quand ça je crains qu effectivement sous
prétexte effectivement de lutter
ou contre l'islamisme et mme bien c'est
l'ensemble des français qui vont voir
leur liberté naturelle et bien régressé
alors ça effectivement ça nous amène à
au projet de loi actuellement voté à
l'assemblée nationale sur le respect des
principes de la république mais ça nous
amènerait trop loin car le temps qui
nous était imparti est désormais couler
merci beaucoup à tous les deux merci en
particulier pour la première partie de
ce débat il est rare de voir sur un
plateau d opinion aussi radicalement
divergentes et un respect mutuels aussi
aussi parfait entre les deux points de
vue tant que je vous remercie pour ça au
nom de nos internautes
bonsoir à tous et bon week-end